le fond de l'enquête maintenant très
clairement c'est de savoir si le prix
méditation ou pas pour le moment elle
est pas retenue mais les enquêteurs
quand même ont de gros soupçons il y a
énormément d'indices lui il dit je l'ai
tué involontairement puis elle n'est pas
morte tout de suite elle lui dit appelle
les secours il panique selon son récit
il va cacher le corps il va cacher là ça
paraît encore une fois aux enquêteurs
absolument impossible alors on va
revenir cette parce que c'est incroyable
parce que il a témoigné dans tous les
médias son mari regardez selon lui sa
femme avait décidé de tout quitter
volontairement et soutenir cette thèse
dans toutes ces interviews
ils l'ont pas compil interview vous
l'avez pas
d'accord alors
dans ces interviews série il disait en
fait qui voulait retrouver sa femme qui
voulait retrouver que c'est ses enfants
ont été inquiets d'ailleurs il a posté
plein de messages sur les réseaux
sociaux le mari pour dire voilà je veux
retrouver à partager partout nous
souhaitons juste avoir des nouvelles
merci à tous et à tous elle manque à
tout le monde à ses enfants à sa famille
et ses proches et à moi-même c'est pour
vous montrer le cynisme
cet ami qui dit il dit moi je suis pas
jubilar je suis pas d'aval mais en fait
dans un instant est-ce qu'il a dit sur
66 minutes c'est incroyable c'est vrai
qu'il a dit non mais je comprends la
suspicion qu'on peut avoir sur moi mais
effectivement parce qu'il y a eu les
affaires jubilar et Daval donc forcément
le mari est toujours sous l'effet des
projecteurs mais je suis aussi inquiet
que vous tous je cherche partout donc
c'est vrai que quand on écoute après a
posteriori et qu'on sait les appeler
alors son ex-femme a été interrogé aussi
un à Michel pial Gilles elle le décrit
comme un mythomane qui se présentait
comme agent secret ou disons qu'il
allait recevoir la Légion d'honneur le
déc également comme un accro aux jeux
d'argent elle aurait fait de terribles
révélations aux enquêteurs selon elle
Michel aurait sans doute essayé de
l'empoisonner elle aurait été la seule à
manger comme il avait dit Michel marine
omelette aux champignons qu'il avait
préparé était tombé gravement malade
ensuite donc voilà ils ont été malade
comme des chiens c'est des mots qu'ils
ont utilisé est-ce que c'était déjà une
tentative de sa part de meurtre on ne le
sait pas mais son profil est extrêmement
inquiétant parce que manipulation
mythomanie mensonge jusqu’où a-t-il
mentir on le voit là dans ces
déclarations que vous soulignez donc on
va juste rappeler qu'il est présumé
innocent mais c'est vrai que son profil
est extrêmement inquiétant on est obligé
de rappeler qu'il est présumé c'est ça
qui incroyable c'est toujours comme ça
sinon tu fais taper dessus tu dois dire
qu'il est présumé de quoi c'est ça qui
est complètement fou parce que non mais
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable parce
que moi je suis un peu comme Raymond le
mec quand tu dis non mais ça c'est lui
qui en est comment pourquoi en fait non
c'est juste un truc technique mais
qu'est-ce qu'on doit dire en fait on est
obligé vraiment qu'est-ce que tu voulais
poser comme question on dit comment on
peut dire quelqu'un qui est présumé
innocent il t'a emmené il a emmené les
gendarmes dans un bois
troisième arbre là-bas ici c'est là
qu'il creuse ou il creuse pas il trouve
parce qu'il est pas bonnet innocent
des aveux j'ai entendu
je suis d'accord avec moi vraiment tu
veux que je te dise ça c'est ça c'est
encore ça c'est ça c'est de l'eau
pactage encore une fois on est obligé
honnête avec les bourreaux
ils le prennent vraiment pas avec
exactement regardez la confit de ce
qu'il a dit sur les différentes télé
on a reçu des messages jusqu'au 31 mars
dernier message me disant que elle était
où elle discutait pas toute seule
qu'elle a accompagnée etc il fallait
passer aux enfants et qu'à partir dans
un petit pays à côté de la France qui
donnerait pas de nouvelles pendant
quelques jours quand elle est partie
pour moi c'était pas possible c'est pour
ça que je t'ai pas soudé qu'elle allait
revenir elle avait lâché plusieurs
choses voilà il y avait des choses
étaient moins présentes qu'elle avait en
fait était présente mais sa tête était
ailleurs tout ce qu'on veut c'est avoir
des nouvelles de Karine juste des
nouvelles c'est juste pour libérer
émotionnellement et rassurer tout le
monde
juste ça
alors derrière il a été plus loin dans
le vif il est également publié de
nombreuses publiques chaussures Facebook
allons dans ce sens la première
publication date du 9 mai soit plus d'un
mois avant la disparition de Karine et
elles s'enchaînent Michel Payet plus de
17 publications concernant la
disparition de Karine sur le réseau
social le 12 mai il partage un article
de France 3 et demande à tout le monde
de le partager également surtout dans le
Sud et si possible en Espagne et
Portugal voir Italie le 26 mai conscient
des doutes le concernant il poste une
citation de Platon personne n'est plus
détesté que celui qui dit la vérité il
est incroyable le premier jour il
diffuse un article de BFM dans lequel il
exprime son intention de déposer plainte
pour cyber-harcèlement et le 4 juin jour
de la fête des mères il publie des
dessins de ses enfants et il s'explique
en ITV regardez c'est incroyable
Michel pial est perçu comme un père
aimant proche de sa famille pourtant et
jusqu'au bout il va manipuler ses
propres enfants pour éloigner tous les
soupçons c'était en date du 4 juin pour
la fête des mères sache que nous pensons
tous très fort à toi les enfants te
souhaitent une bonne fête des mères il
t'aime et tu leur manque beaucoup donne
des nouvelles s'il te plaît en ce jour
de fête des mères il demande à Jules et
Bérénice de faire des dessins pour leur
maman il savait qu'il l'avait tué il a
fait ça il lui a enlevé la vie et après
il a mitonné tout le monde tout son
entourage de ses enfants mais c'est
inhumain
c'est incroyable parce que c'est en fait
c'est hyper violent à posteriori
c'est-à-dire qu'il a construit une
histoire autour de son mensonge il mêle
les enfants c'est totalement sordide
vous rendez compte à quel point il est
manipulateur aller devant toutes les
caméras des missions qui sont très
regardées pour dire voilà donc là on est
en plein dans le mythomane manipulateur
publié des messages sur les réseaux
sociaux mettre ses enfants dedans pour
dire non ce n'est pas moi je ne suis pas
un criminel comme tous ceux qui ont tué
sa femme et en plus il a fait plein de
conneries Cyril parce que il a notamment
jeté le téléphone portable de de Karine
qui était découverte par le maire de la
ville après après son heure il a dit à
ses voisins qu'en fait elle était dans
une forêt je ne sais où alors que à
d'autres il a dit qu'elle était ailleurs
bref plein d'incohérences comme ça qui
l'ont amené à faire ses aveux là et
quand on voit aujourd'hui ce qui dit
dans les médias ça glace le sang alors
c'est vrai que alors lui c'est un ancien
architecte qui vend des objets d'art en
ligne et à d'ailleurs plusieurs fois il
a été plusieurs fois qu'on allait pour
avoir escroquer des clients
il a été condamné à 8 reprises entre 98
et 2021 pour des faits de contrefaçon
d'escroquerie et de falsification de
chaque volet une vie de fausseté une vie
de faussée et d'ailleurs ah ça les
épouses c'est compagnie disait je vais
être super riche je vais avoir la Légion
d'Honneur Serge Dassault va me payer des
fortunes etc
et rien n'arrivait tout était inventé il
s'est inventé une vie jusqu'à très
probablement devenir incriminel vous
parlez de sa belle-famille tout à
l'heure Cyril il a même escroqué sa
belle famille en faisant donc passer
pour un espion en leur disant qu'ils
allaient gagner beaucoup d'argent s'il
pouvait en emprunter donc même sa propre
famille a été victime de de son
personnage et de son escroquerie alors
ça me rappelle ça me rappelle un film ça
rappelle l'adversaire c'était une
histoire vraie
docteur roman
exactement on va revoir sur 66 minutes
sont venus sur cette affaire pour une
proche de Karine
Michel avait forcément quelque chose à
se reprocher regarder
hier le mari de Karine a été placé en
garde à vue elle décrit un homme parfois
étrange souvent il utilisait le compte
Facebook de sa femme parce qu'à un
moment Michel va intervenir sur des
conversations privées que j'ai avec
Karine Véronique le répète elle ne veut
pas accuser le mari de Karine mais
l'appel à coopérer s'il y est pour
quelque chose et ben voilà qui le disent
faut qu'on sache où et car il faut qu'on
sache si elle est morte où elle est il
faut que les enfants puissent faire leur
deuil que la famille de Karine puisse
faire leur deuil que ses amis puissent
faire leur deuil
alors il y a quelques indices toujours
de la disparition de Karine Michel est
allé chercher les enfants en retard ça
les transpirant c'est ce que nous disait
Michel Marie une maman de l'école proche
de Karine raconte
Jules et Bérénice ce sont les enfants de
Karine et Michel la surveillante du
collège est arrivée à leur hauteur alors
dit vous bougez pas papa il arrive vous
restez dans la vous restez là Michel
arrive avec du retard sale et
transpirant mais il prend soin de
prévenir Emmanuel par SMS sa femme
Karine l'aurait quitté précipitamment
j'ai envoyé le message à Karine il était
17h45 ce jour-là coucou ma belle Michel
m'a dit que tu étais parti je comprends
que tu aies eu un ras-le-bol ça nous
arrive à toutes de te connaissant je
suis sûr que tu laisseras pas tes petits
bouts appelle-moi quand tu veux j'avais
jamais eu de réponse
la sœur de Karine la semaine dernière
ici sur le plateau elle avait décrit
déjà cette espèce de manipulation
d'emprise qui pouvait avoir aussi sur sa
femme elle avait pas de téléphone
portable Karine il surveillait aussi
tous les appels elle n'avait pas de
compte de réseaux sociaux etc c'est lui
qui avait la main mise en fait sur tout
ce qu'elle pouvait faire les
communications etc donc il y avait quand
même des signaux d'alarme qui ont pas
été malheureusement vu et par la famille
et par alors le téléphone de Karine a
été retrouvé quelques jours après la
disparition de la mère de famille au
bord d'une route c'est le maire de la
ville qui l'a retrouvé il a rapporté à
Michel et la réaction de ce dernier a
surpris beaucoup surpris le maire
regardez
lors d'une promenade sur le bord de
cette départementale très fréquenté le
maire de mâché découvre un téléphone
portable je l'ai trouvé là dans le fond
du fossé un téléphone très propre en
parfait état avec un niveau de batterie
tout à fait raisonnable on éclaire qu'il
était pas là depuis longtemps un détail
va encore le surprendre d'avantage j'ai
découvert donc une photo et cette photo
c'était celle d'évaluation pial la
l'aîné de du couple à ce moment-là le
mérignore que la famille est sans
nouvelles de Karine depuis plus de 10
jours c'est ce qu'il apprend en
contactant Michel pial il était pas
paniqué il était il paraissait pas du
tout inquiet au téléphone du tout du
tout du tout j'ai pris le téléphone je
l'ai mis dans sa boîte aux lettres
j'espère que dans quelques temps on va
pas nous on va pas nous dire oui il est
fou il va finir à l'hôpital
psychiatrique s'il avoué et qu'il a
vraiment tué sa femme et qui en plus
dans dans quelques semaines
par exemple peut-être que les enfants
ont besoin eux d'un procès ils ont
besoin de comprendre
c'est justement un procès mais c'est sûr
comme très souvent il y a un procès non
plus
mais on le sait à chaque fois sur
beaucoup d'affaires comme ça où il y a
des choses très graves qui se passent ça
ça part en problèmes cicatrique problème
psychologique et ça finit en HP alors
que ça devrait finir derrière les
barreaux voilà le mec a tué
là on a vu on a vu que c'était un
manipulateur là à mon avis voilà voilà
il est pas il est pas mythomane maladies
etc alors selon lui donc il s'agirait
d'un accident il aurait été il aurait
tiré dessus accidentellement avec une
carabine qu'il nettoyait à la fin de sa
garde à vue la mené les gendarmes
jusqu'à un bois si tu as Chalon à une
quinzaine de kilomètres au domicile
familial ils ont leur retrouver le corps
de Karine et donc il a été mise en
examen pour meurtre sur euh exactement
alors en fait pendant la garde à vue ils
ont réussi à resserrer le filet
resserrer les taux et il a fini par
craquer parce que les profs
s'accumulaient autour de lui et à un
moment il a complètement craquer il a
avoué il était totalement acculé par les
enquêteurs qui lorsqu'ils l'ont mis en
garde à vue ça avait déjà à quel
résultat il voulait arriver et ce qu'il
voulait obtenir ils ont réussi alors
vendredi et lorsque on a su les aveux
hein de de du mari de Karine Bruce tout
ça demandait au journaliste experts poli
justice Maxime brunstetter de livrer des
informations sur l'état dans lequel se
trouvait les proches de Karine et il y a
eu un énorme bug regardez on va
retrouver Maxime qui suit cette affaire
pour BFM TV depuis le depuis le début
Maxime est-ce qu'on sait comment la la
famille les proches de Karine réagissent
depuis
malheureusement ce dénouement
très bien ils sont heureux
une petite fête est prévue ce soir au
village
faudrait les les proches de Karine
déjà elle est proche l'entourage en
règle générale les amis très largement
eux ils sont tous effondrés alors c'est
incroyable
alors en fait c'est la suite des gens
qui étaient des gens lisses qui sont
prévus pour les duplex et il y en a un
qui avait le micro ouvert et qui a voulu
faire une blague alors c'est totalement
inadmissible et c'est très grave c'est
très grave alors c'est très grave parce
que c'est
blessant dégradant terrible pour la fête
pour les gens qui regardent ça dénote
quand même de la part de celui qui a dit
ça un mépris pour la souffrance des gens
et imaginez ces BFM alors ils se sont
excusés ils plaident le problème
technique imaginez simplement que ce
soit à nous c'est ça comme un pilori
dessus voilà technique et ça passe non
ça peut pas passer on peut pas passer
c'est une blague en plus c'est une
blague volontaire
franchement c'est honteux
première chaîne info de France un truc
comme ça si comme disait Gilles un
chroniqueur avait son micro en verre
comme ça il tente une vanne ça pas chez
nous
sur BFM donc ce que je vais faire
puisque BFM à chaque fois moi il
m'arrive un truc ils mettent un bandeau
on aurait dû faire un bandeau toute la
journée voilà bug sur la tête et on le
fera pas forcément parce que c'est pour
la famille qu'on le fait pas et on pense
d'abord aux familles eux c'est vrai que
quand il nous arrive un truc on est tout
le temps au bon dos hein sur BFM toute
la journée ils font toutes leurs
émissions sur nous hein
c'est pas un problème technique
journaliste
un problème technique il a raison ouais
technique c'est voilà
après technique là c'est pas la première
fois Emmanuel le chiffre il avait fait
ça aussi sur la même chaîne
enterrement il parlait de des asiatures
c'est très bien les Pokémon la même
chose aussi je demande la même chose
aussi pour le gars
il faut une sanction c'est pas grave de
nous faire croire que c'est un problème
technique c'est bien une technique
regardez j'aimerais qu'on voit ça parce
que quand vous savez ça veut dire que
quand il prend l'antenne il y a un mec
qui était donc de l'équipe voilà c'est
ça
qui suit cette affaire pour BFM TV
depuis le depuis le début Maxime est-ce
qu'on sait comment la la famille les
proches de Karine réagissent depuis
malheureusement ce dénouement
très bien ils sont heureux une petite
fête est prévue ce soir au village
très les proches de Karine
déjà elle est proche l'entourage en
règle générale les amis très largement
eux ils sont tous effondrés mais c'est
incroyable ça je vous jure je le revois
je ne sais pas les téléspectateurs ce
que vous en pensez ça c'est fou
mais t'imagines ce serait passé c'est
chez nous ça c'est
un grand journaliste
ça a été enchaîné après derrière un
commentaire même lui je pense qu'il a
même pas pensé
c'est bon c'est pas le souci tu peux
rien faire il peut rien faire
la gueule de sa question aussi on est
dans quel état d'esprit la famille
exactement c'est genre maintenant
connard exactement tu as raison c'est ça
c'est ça
aussi grave et dramatique bien sûr
excusez
[Musique]
voilà il s'excusait assez vite mais les
mecs nous aussi
c'est pas c'est pas ça
c'est
une suite à une mauvaise blague
exactement c'est pas grave des sanctions
seront prises tu vois un truc comme ça
voilà mais c'est pas c'est pas euh sinon
pas leur place nous présentons c'est pas
une erreur technique c'est pas du tout
une erreur technique pour le moment
c'est faible les excuses sont faibles
par rapport à l'ampleur de ce qui s'est
passé et du scandale
je suis désolé
aussi mais il y a une fonction
de l'antenne je suis désolé nous les
mecs on met un pantalon noir et ils vont
dire ouais il fallait que c'était du
blanc aujourd'hui ils vont nous mettre
200000 ils sont froid quand c'est nous
ils sont moins pro à réagir là c'est le
moment il faut le dire alors comme aussi
c'est vrai qu'ils sont très peu c'est
nous là là normalement là je vous dis
nous c'est la même chose je vous dis on
prend 3 millions un dîner sans double
vitesse ah non mais je te le dis ça
c'est sûr tu prends un million et demi
voilà comme ça tu prends un million et
demi d'euros c'est sûr d'amende eux donc
il y a pas de il y a pas de pour le
moment là il y a encore de suite
regardez pour signaler c'est toujours
pas c'est ça c'est vrai que nous la
chance d'être très bien
il a raison je pense que là avec ce
qu'on a fait ce soir les pauvres on leur
a pas rendu service et bien sûr qu'on va
être signaler finalement du coup faire
plus d'audience là que le matin tu es
sûr qu'on a le machin 180000 je crois
voilà 170000 c'est sûr que oui c'est
vrai que puis donc 100000 qui dort donc
forcément c'est compliqué